From master animator Miyazaki, one of the most influential filmmakers of all time,...
...comes a groundbreaking motion picture event.
In a time when gods walked the Earth,...
...an epic battle rages...
...between the encroaching civilization of man and the gods of the forest.
When the forest has been cleared and the wolves wiped out,...
...this place will be the richest land in the world.
It's a war which threatens to unbalance the forces of nature.
It will be a battle the humans will never forget.
Now, the fate of the world rests on the courage of one fearless princess.
I'm not afraid to die.
And I would do anything to get the humans out of here.
And one brave warrior.
You fight like a demon, boy, like something possessed.
What exactly are you here for?
To see with eyes unclouded by hate.
Now, watch closely everyone. I'm going to show you how to kill a god.
Fire!
You cannot alter your fate.
However, you can rise to meet it if you choose.
Featuring the voices of Gillian Anderson, Billy Crudup,...
...Claire Danes, Minnie Driver, Jada Pinkett-Smith, and Billy Bob Thornton.
Princess Mononoke.